TERRENCE RYAN: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get into them all.
So if you didn't
see GCP 101, then
stay tuned, because
here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Starting on Google Cloud can
be overwhelming at first.
There are over 40
products spread
over a huge set of cloud
technologies, like machine
learning, containers,
or big data.
It could be hard to
decide where to dig in.
In my talk, I took people
on a journey of someone
bringing their first
test application
to Google Cloud Platform.
Let's see if we can shed
some light on this path
and help you figure out where
you want to go with GCP.
One of the first things anybody
coming to any cloud does
is what we call
a Lift and Shift.
That's when you pick
up an app that's
running in your
current environment
and drop it to another.
Now, most people
start this process
from existing systems
running on either bare metal
host or virtual
machines of their own,
usually in their
own data centers.
On the Cloud side of this
move, virtual machines
are really the basic building
block of the solution.
And on Google Cloud Platform,
that means Compute Engine.
Now, I'm going to
attempt to explain
all the benefits
of Compute Engine
in the time it takes me to get
one of our virtual machines up
and running.
But first, let's jump into
the console to create it.
You see here, I have
options around which
of our worldwide data centers
you can host your VMs.
I can change the machine
size, or the boot disk's
basic firewall options,
and even choose
to launch a container image by
itself in a virtual machine.
I'm going to largely choose
the defaults here and launch.
Then, I'm going to
take a deep breath.
And then, I'm going
to try and spell out
all the benefits
of Compute Engine
before it finishes launching.
Compute Engine instances
are highly configurable VMs
that allow you to choose
both preset and custom
amounts of processor memory
and processor platforms.
You have several storage
options, including
networked SSD and attached SSD.
Use any of our disk images based
on several flavors of Linux
or Windows to start or bring
your own customized image.
You
Can also take advantage of
some more specialized computing
resources, like GPUs and TPUs.
You can manage all of
your VMs, regardless
of where in the world they
are, on one screen and one
interface.
And this just isn't a feature of
the console for managing them.
All of your VMs are
on the same network
by default, with no
manual setup required
to get your VM in Sydney to
talk to your VM in London.
And we're done.
And you can tell we're done
because we have this little SSH
button.
So I couldn't get it done in
the time it took to launch.
But let's go ahead.
We'll SSH in.
So now, we'll use that to
correct right to the VM
through the browser--
no pulling down and
customizing certs, setting up
all the necessary security.
We'll do that for you.
From here, I can
customize my VM,
installing whatever software I
need to start making it mine.
[KEYBOARD CLICKING]
But I don't have to SSH directly
into the box to do that.
With the G Cloud
CLI tools, I can
do everything I need to do
to make this machine mine
right from the comfort of
my own terminal window.
Pure Lift and Shift really only
requires a virtual machine.
But moving to the
Cloud allows you
to take advantage
of a lot of systems
that you can't duplicate in
your own environment-- things
like distributed
storage, distributed
databases, or machine learning
APIs and big data tools.
In the full video,
I spoke about how
best to take an application you
brought to the Cloud via Lift
and Shift and re-architect it
to take advantage of everything
that Google Cloud has to offer.
I go over using Cloud
storage and Cloud SQL
to make your app
much more scalable.
I also explored some
of the other computing
options that open up to you
when you make those architecture
changes.
Finally, I'll point you
to a number of other tools
that you can use to improve your
application, including machine
learning APIs, and logging,
and other communication tools.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link
in description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
Channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]